si les réactions politiques à l'appel
lancée hier soir aux Français par le
président Mitterrand varie comme il se
doit au gré de l'éventail politique
critique à droite vous avez peut-être
entendu dans notre journal de 12h45
messieurs le Canuel éponge critique
positive bien sûr à gauche le Parti
communiste parle la voix de son
secrétaire général Georges Marchais a
exprimé ce soir sa réaction aux propos
du chef de l'État écoutons monsieur
marché
le président de la République la déclaré
hier avec raison
la politique suivie jusqu'ici et bonne
il s'agit maintenant de poursuivre
les communistes vont de faire avec le
même esprit de responsabilité
le même engagement au gouvernement et
dans le pays
oui il faut vaincre le chômage
oui il faut réduire l'inflation
oui il faut assainir la situation du
commerce extérieur
c'est un impératif national
nous allons y contribuer
cela va demander des efforts
c'est évident
et nous ne nous en effrayons pas la
justice exige
qu'on ne demande pas plus aux uns qui
ont déjà tant de mal à vivre mais
beaucoup plus aux autres qui n'ont fait
jusqu'ici que profiter des difficultés
du pays monsieur marchait aussi précisé
que la souscription lancée par le Parti
communiste pour la campagne des
municipales a rapporté 40 millions de
francs